en primer lugar quisiera preguntarle a
qué atribuye usted este movimiento
político por parte del castillo de
reformular su gabinete hacia lo que es
considerado como una tendencia más
moderada y qué consecuencias cree que
podría tener
gracias por limitación bueno el cambio
del gabinete hacia un contexto de como
bien decías de crisis e inestabilidad
de enfrentamientos sobre todo dentro del
gobierno entre el ejecutivo y el
congreso desde el congreso se alistaba
una moción de censura contra el ministro
de trabajo idioma iber maraví y terminó
siendo retirado el cargo y la respuesta
anunciada por el primer ministro de vido
era de una cuestión de confianza para
buscar evitar justamente la censura de
maravilla entonces había este choque
digamos de poderes había espacio de
inestabilidad y justamente ayer en su
mensaje a la nación y por lo que podemos
averiguar antes también cuando una
fuente es el presidente era tener una
mejor comunicación con el congreso bajar
las tensiones y por eso llevó a realizar
este cambio no sólo de iber maraví sino
de otros ministros en total han sido
renovados siete ministerios 12 ministros
y en sus cargos pero como renuncia el
ministro pues tiene que renovarse el
gabinete en su totalidad
en cuanto a las consecuencias bueno ya
desde la bancada oficialista
precisamente de perú libre han señalado
su rechazo a este nuevo gabinete porque
dicen que les han dado otras partidarias
no es parte de los lineamientos del
partido y ahí está comunicó en estos
momentos precisamente hacia este punto
va mi próxima pregunta porque como bien
decía desde el ala más radical del
partido perú libre surgieron varias
acusaciones incluso hablan de traición y
amenazan con no otorgar el voto de
confianza al nuevo gabinete que podemos
esperar en este sentido
bueno el discurso entre ayer y hoy ha
variado un poco ayer el vocero de esta
bancada
valdemar sharron hermano del secretario
general del partido la hiniesta roma
representante el digamos a la más
radical de la bancada señalaba ayer que
esto era una tradición que saben cuando
el gabinete hoy día como aquí ha bajado
un poco el tono y han visto que están
respaldando de todos modos al presente
castillo otras voces de la bancada ella
hablan que van a evaluar el voto de
confianza que todavía no está nada
decidido
otro sector de la bancada si está
totalmente a favor de darle el voto de
confianza entonces lo que va a venir a
varias una seguramente una ronda de
diálogos entre la nueva primera ministra
y las bancadas de hecho con la banca
oficialista también los congresistas
oficialistas y en reunirse nuevamente
con el presidente castillo en la idea es
un poco de llegar a acuerdos de mayores
acciones para mi gabinete y seguramente
reiterarla el presidente que mantenga la
línea que ha mantenido estos momentos
ahora además de lograr algo clave como
es la gobernabilidad del país que otros
desafíos se enfrenta el nuevo ejecutivo
peruano
bueno de hecho sigue la atención en las
medidas de atención a la pandemia
estamos en proceso de vacunación
observamos la vacunación de 18 años está
la reactivación económica justamente
hace unos minutos se presente el
castillo acaba de confirmar la
permanencia de julio velarde al frente
del banco central de reserva el perú
pero anuncia esperado
de la figura de velarde reconocida aquí
en el país
había cierta incertidumbre que había
afectado también parte de la economía
entonces la salud la reactivación
económica la generación de empleo el
aspecto educativo pero lo educativo
también son grandes retos que tiene este
gabinete y que tiene en realidad el
gobierno de castilla